Well, one one of the reasons that most
people don't realize is that the Islamic
State uh in fact always issues these
kind of um calls telling them to do
precisely that. It tells Muslims that if
you're living in the West, terrorize
them. Don't forget you're a member of
the Islamic State and drive your trucks
into them. Drive your cars into them. Go
stab them. Um attack civilians. Don't
attack uh military. In other words,
attack whatever is easy and soft
targets. Um, so one of the reasons that
they're instructed to by these Islamic
radicals and the other is
>> where are these Islamic radicals?
>> Where are they?
>> Yeah. [laughter]
>> Everywhere. You mean ISIS? Where are
they?
>> Well, I don't know. I mean, um, the one
there's a they issue a magazine uh that
comes out every couple weeks and, you
know, comes online in the darknet and
uh, but and that's another term, you
know, when you a lot of people get
caught up. Okay, I understand there's
bad guys. It's ISIS, it's al-Qaeda,
etc., etc. I don't get caught up in
these these kind of terms because the
issue we're talking about is ideological
and it transcends these finite
organizations that come and go.
>> What about the Muslim Brotherhood?
>> Well, they're they're known as the sort
of granddaddy of all these
organizations. Al-Qaeda was u you know
Aean Zawahari, I was telling you about
seed Cook of Muslim Brotherhood. He's
one of the earliest. Aean Zawahari was
also who became the leader of al-Qaeda
was formerly the Muslim Brotherhood. and
the difference that the Muslim
Brotherhood and these groups have. So
for example, in the writings of Aean
Alwahari which I translated from Arabic
way way back almost two decades ago. Um
he complained about the Muslim
Brotherhood because they're too patient
and they take a sort of incremental
approach and they don't want to do jihad
which is in fact what makes them more
dangerous. So he was more representative
of the sort of ISIS thing which is I
want to do jihad now. You know I want to
go kill the infidel. Whereas the Muslim
Brotherhood it's just a subversive kind
of power. And I don't know if you know,
but the FBI actually caught some
documents back in 2009 that actually are
from the Muslim Brotherhood talking
about how they're waging a
civilizational jihad in America, trying
to subvert, etc., etc., and all these
organizations that are branches from it
like CARE, the Council on American
Islamic Relations. So, these are the
groups that are engaged in what I told
you, the jihad of the tongue, the jihad
of the pen, the jihad of um, you know,
the money. They're all working for the
same purpose that ISIS is, but through
legal measures, um, you know, through
propaganda and whatnot. And I know that
to someone who is as indepth with all
this stuff as you, these questions may
sound kind of naive,
>> but what do they want? What is that
designed to achieve? What's the point of
that?
>> That's actually a good question. So on
the one hand, and this is actually
really interesting because there's a
school of thought. So I told you about
ISIS issuing these um these uh
directives.
A lot of Muslims in the Muslim world
tell you ISIS isn't an Islamic
organization. It's actually working uh
for western elements to make people hate
Muslims. And honestly, when I see
because you asked a good question, what
is the point in telling Muslims go and
stab people? What does that do? Does
that somehow have a strategic purpose?
All it does is make people hate Muslims,
right? I mean, that's that's the logic.
And I'm only I'm not telling you this is
what I believe, but I've never I've the
civilizational jihad via the Muslim
Brotherhood. That makes more sense to me
than these organizations who just say,
"Hey, all they literally the the Islamic
State once said they issued a a kind of
one of their declarations at the peak of
uh you know the I think it was the
beginning of the um when the Israeli
Palestinian stuff a couple years ago and
they told Muslims, don't attack Israel
because if you do, you're going to only
empower Hamas and they're not true
Muslims and the PLO. Okay? and instead
we want you and then they attacked Iran.
It was in the context of of they killed
like 100 people in Kermon
>> and so they said this is we're attacking
Iran because Iran's evil stupid Shia you
know Sunn Shia and why would you want to
fight Israel and help these other guys
like the PLO who are not true Muslims
instead go to Europe and do that crash
into them decapitate them and and throw
terror in their hearts and everyone in
the Arab world said see this is not real
ISIS but on the other hand what they are
teaching is in the Quran So when they so
Quran 95 famously it's known as a sword
verse and it tells Muslims it's actually
remember I was telling about Jefferson
talking with an ambassador he basically
paraphrased it that verse says when you
know the forbidden months have passed
wait slay the idolattors wherever you
find them the pagans lay and wait for
them ambush them terrorize them okay
>> so what you're saying is and correct me
if I'm misunderstanding this is not
strategic this is doctrinal
>> yeah from from the Islamic state that's
what I argue and this is why a lot of
other Muslim groups who have the same
goal they'd like to see Islamic
hedgemony around the world um don't take
that route because to them you're even
al-Qaeda for example which is ISIS when
I translated the writing so what they
said to the west was we're doing this
because you attacked us we're doing this
because you support Israel we're doing
this because you didn't sign the Kyoto
protocol it was always a griev seriously
it was a grievance after grievance and
it was had nothing to do with doctrine
Then the writings I came across this is
my first book the al-Qaeda reader which
came out in 2007 and the reason it was a
kind of a big deal at the time I was
working at the library of congress and I
came all across these Arabic writings by
Osama bin Laden and Aman Zahari and they
said now they now they sounded like ISIS
and it was we're we hate them not
because of what they do it's because
they're infidels and we have to hate the
infidels and we have to fight them and
we have to do jihad. Okay. So even
al-Qaeda was smart enough to, you know,
play the double game and and say, "Hey,
we're we're only doing this to you
because you you hit us first." But ISIS
is is so to me, I always say the
refreshingly honest, but in a way that
doesn't really help the cause as a lot
of Muslims point out because what you're
doing is you're sort of exposing us and
yeah, when you go and you stab toddlers
in the UK or whatever, what is that?
How's that helping from a strategic
point? So it's it's a it's a good
question. if Islam can be changed. Okay.
And immediately I'm struck with a quote
from the Encyclopedia of Islam which is
written by a jurist and he said Islam
needs to be completely made over for the
doctrine of jihad which it defined as
what I defined which is unprovoked
warfare to conquer the world. Okay. He
said it had to be remade over. Can that
be done? I suppose. Um but it would not
it would no longer really be Islam. And
I think I mean if you look around at
certain versions of Christianity I mean
that's the case there. that's not
historic Christianity. So I suppose that
can be done. Um you know the examples
you gave of these central Asian
countries, it's very interesting because
you know they are nominal Muslims but
like you said they're the first ones who
clamp down on that stuff because they
will be the first victims.
>> It's even the Muslim Brotherhood is
outlawed in Egypt where it was born,
>> right? But at the same time, Cece and
his government pays a lot of lip service
and is engaged in Islamizing Egypt and
he will ally with the Celifies who are
actually more ideologically draconian
than Muslim Brotherhood. So there's a
lot of kind of like shifting back and
forth with how this works. But you know
the bottom line is Islam is what Islam
is. Okay. And unlike other religions,
it's very black and white. you know the
the whole concept the problem with
western people is they project their own
religion kind of and they then they're
convinced that for example Christianity
is you know separation of secular and
and spiritual you know Caesar the coin
and whatnot but that's not Islam Islam
is not it's not about the condition of
your heart and relationship you have
with God it's actually all about the law
it's legalistic and uh in fact and
everything in Islam is there's five you
know either it's forbidden you can't do
It's disliked. You shouldn't do but you
can technically it's neutral. You can or
don't have to do. It's recommended. You
should do but you don't have to. Or it's
obligatory everything in life. So Islam
really permeates. So can it change? Can
they rearticulate it? I suppose. But
you're always going to have the
hardliners who say, "Hey, that's not
what our book says. That's not what the
Quran says. That's not what Muhammad
said in the hadith." Um so I think it
would actually be easier to just snuff
it out altogether. Um from Muslims
themselves. In other words, I always
find the apostate more honest with
himself or herself than the moderate
Muslim. And uh because the apostate is
kind of like, you look, I'm not going to
kid myself. It is what it is. And I
don't want to be like that. Whereas the
moderate, you know, they engage in so
all these um sort of intellectual
gymnastics in their head to get by. I
mean, if if Muhammad himself in a
canonical hadith says whoever the
apostate, kill him. Okay? or you know or
in the Quran itself you are allowed to
you it's permissible for a man to have
sex slaves infidel female sex slaves as
many as your right hand possess okay
these sorts of things if if I'm a Muslim
and I don't want to accept that for
example you know what do you do with
those verses and I often watch in Arabic
these clerics [clears throat] and that's
what they say remember I was telling you
about um the one guy who was basically
saying yeah if you're married to a
Christian you can but you have to hate
her and lo and behold a lot of the
people sitting there were kind of
questioning like are you serious and he
finally gets frustrated he goes well
it's written you know what do you do
with the verses that I just quoted
including you know you got to hate
Abraham and whatnot so the crux of the
matter is the religion itself which is
so easily identified and clear-cut
teaches what we call radical things okay
um they're only radical from our
perspective subjective perspective
they're not radical from a Muslim point
of view
>> well but that's where that's exactly the
point I'm putting to which is it's
clearly is radical from the perspective
of the rulers of the UAE from the rulers
of Saudi.
>> Right. Right. It's radical because it's
radical to them because they can suffer
from it because they're not seen as
legitimate Muslim rulers.
>> Right.
>> And at the same time, they have to pay
lip service to Islam. So they're not in
other words, a lot of these rulers are
just not Muslim at heart obviously and
they're but they govern Muslims. So they
want to create the most, you know, on
the one hand they want to be legitimate
and show their legitimacy as hey I can
be your ruler. uh and which means they
have to kind of let you know let the pot
kind of steam come out a little bit so
the Muslims can feel this is actual
Islam and on the other hand they got to
kind of clamp down on on certain
teachings. So that's why a lot of these
rulers um are often just you know
denounced as you know puppets of the
west and not true Muslims including the
ones in Saudi Arabia who are actually
nominal Wahhabis which is as radical as
you can get and in fact they do
disseminate and and and play a huge role
in sort of uh disseminating jihadist
literature and they're still hated and
seen as pawns of the Best.